this shelter in the city of Port Sudan
houses people forced from their homes by
the war but for many the conditions are
barely tolerable
the electricity is off for three hours
five hours and six hours
the temperature is very high and the
children have boils on their faces
mosquitoes are all over the place we
burn wood to get rid of the mosquitoes
the frequent blackouts have badly
affected most services in the city
especially hospitals and medical centers
one of the biggest government hospitals
depends on a private generator for
electricity costing more than a thousand
dollars a day
the electric generator needs three
barrels of fuel per day the cost is
around 1 000 US Dollars Which is far too
much for the hospital's resources we've
lived through difficult tough times
during this last period
engineers at the state electricity
company are having to repair the network
nearly every day but a dispute
overpayment between Sudanese authorities
and their Turkish energy supplier has
also led to Cuts
huge efforts being made by the state
government the Federal Ministry of
Finance and the electrical engineers we
hope the problem will be sorted out very
soon God willing
the city of Port Sudan is a coastal city
and is approaching the summer season in
addition to that the city also hosts a
very large number of displaced people
due to the conditions in the country
with disruption from the war
increasingly affecting people around the
country many here say the power outages
are worsening the crisis and are now an
urgent priority